fouiller pour trouver les vestiges du
temps passer et fouilles et pour
connaître ses origines
l'archéologie est une science qui permet
d'étudier l'homme depuis la préhistoire
jusqu'à l'époque contemporaine à travers
une technique de mise à jour des
vestiges matériels ayant subsister et 19
20 et 21 juin dernier
archéologie tête à l'honneur avec les
journées nationales qui lui sont dédiés
et lazaret en partenariat avec l'adda qu
ils ont proposé des ateliers où les
jeunes ont pu se familiariser avec un
chantier de fouilles j'ai appris le
métier d'archéologue qui me tue à
ramasser des objets 21 enfin dans le
simulateur et pas à priver de constituer
trouver des objets pour composer
le vase c'est super blindé
le chef shebab le lazaret qui proposait
une activité pour les plus jeunes mais
également une découverte pour les
adolescents les adultes
cette fois ci une fouille de sépulture
ces trois journées le lazaret propose en
partenariat avec l'adda khôi des
ateliers d'initiation à la fouille
archéologique pour les enfants de 6 à 12
ans un atelier un peu plus spécifique
d'initiation à la fouille
anthropologique donc à la fouille d'une
sépulture évidemment factice pour les
adolescents et les adultes parallèle
nous avons notre offre culturelle
permanente à savoir nos expositions et
plus particulièrement celles sur le
chantier archéologique du lazaret numéro
2 l'archéologie pour écrire l'histoire
où le public pourra découvrir les
résultats de ce chantier archéologique
qui s'est déroulé en 2012
trois jours très riche pour les
collégiens mais aussi les passionnés
d'archéologie et visiteurs pouvaient
également découvrir une exposition
dédiée à l'archéologie océan indien
cet après midi l'intervention sur des
collégiens des classes de 4e ou là
c'était un peu plus poussée au niveau de
la pédagogie ils ont ils découvert de
l'exposition sur l'archéologie océan
indien donc une communication des
questions que ça soit la réunion et
mayotte et on a enchaîné avec un atelier
sur la découverte du métier
d'archéologue les techniques de fouilles
jusqu'à la post folk et le remontage des
céramiques le lazaret de la grande
chaloupe un site prédestiné pour partir
la découverte du métier d'archéologue
mais également ensuite pour mieux
comprendre l'histoire des engagés qui
sont passés par la quarantaine et
surtout mieux comprendre comment ils ont
vécu cette période d'isolement